MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we
have a very brief view
at the current status
of Higgs boson research.
And I have to tell you
that we could spend
an entire week discussing this.
I just give you the
high-level overview, maybe
the 30,000 feet kind
of overview of what
we know about the Higgs boson.
On the Canvas page,
you'll find a reference
to a summary report,
which gives you
a little bit more information
than I give you here.
But I do think that there's
a few things to highlight.
And those are the ones which
I'm going to talk about.
The first part is that we
have discovered the Higgs
boson in decays to photons and
also in decays to the Z bosons.
Where the Z boson itself
decays into a pair of leptons,
electrons and muons.
And the detectors
we have available--
and here is an example
for ATLAS and for CMS--
they are very good in measuring
with precision the energy
or momenta of photons,
electrons, and muons.
So this allows us
to then reconstruct
the mass of the Higgs boson
as it goes through the decay.
And you can see
this here, this is
125 GeV reconstructed
two-photon final state.
So we have Higgs--
two photons from ATLAS.
You see that there
is a slight bump
over an enormous background.
So those are other
sources of diphoton events
which are produced
in a hadron collider.
But when you subtract those two
spectra which is shown here,
data minus background, you see
this beautiful peak of Higgs
to gamma gamma events.
Similarly, Higgs to ZZ--
and I put a little star here,
because one of the Z bosons
has to be off-shell.
Z boson mass is 91 GeV, the
mass of the Higgs boson 125 GeV.
So 91 plus 91 is 128.
So one has to be a
little off its mass peak.
And then we look at decays
into e plus e minus,
and mu plus mu minus,
and combination of those,
for example for muon events and
for electron events as well.
Also shown here, and again,
you have this beautiful peak
consistent with the Higgs
boson at a mass of 125 GeV.
And again, you have
other processes
which contribute to
this final state,
namely the one where you
have the four leptons coming
from the Z boson itself and/or
from a pair of Z bosons,
as is shown here.
There's also
processes which mimic
the leptons in the detector.
Those have to be
evaluated as well.
And they're typically shown
here in this plot here in green.
OK.
So as you can imagine, we can
measure the cross-section very
precisely, because we can
identify those particles well.
But we can also
measure the mass.
And this is shown here.
This is a summary of
measurements from ATLAS and CMS
using those to final
states, one with two photons
or the one with four leptons.
And you see that measurements
are generally in agreement,
and they can be combined to
this measurement of 125 GeV.
And the best, the combined
value is shown here.
So this is a
precision measurement.
And since the Higgs
boson mass now
is the only unknown
parameter of the Higgs
in the standard
model, we know and can
check all other properties.
And one is the coupling strength
to the bosons, which we just
looked at already, or
the coupling strength
to the fermions.
So this is two
examples, one that's
showing Higgs to
tau tau events--
tau plus tau minus.
And you see again, there's a
lot of background processes
which mimic-- have the
same signature, the signal.
But we can find,
when you subtract
the background from the
data, the nexus of event,
again at 125 GeV.
So taus themselves decay, and
they decay into neutrinos,
which cannot be measured
at these detectors.
Therefore, the
mass reconstruction
is much harder than in the
final stage we discussed before.
That is easier in
this final state,
where we have a Higgs into
two muons, mu plus mu minus.
The issue here is that
the weight is very small.
The number of Higgs
boson decaying to mu mu
is very small.
But there's also a large
amount of background.
So again, very similar to
the Higgs to gamma gamma
final state we looked at before.
We have a huge
amount of background.
And here by eye, you
don't even see the bump.
You see the bump
a little bit when
you do data minus background.
It's a fraction.
You see this small
axis here, which
is consistent with 3
standard deviations.
So the likelihood
of the background
to fluctuate without the
presence of the Higgs signal
is about 3 standard deviations.
All right.
This information
then can be used
to extract information
about the couplings itself.
And this is a
beautiful plot here,
which shows the Higgs
coupling on one axis,
either to the
fermions or the boson,
versus the mass of the particle.
And so you find your favorite
particle, the top, the W, Z,
the bottom, the
tau, and the muon.
Those are the ones where we can
actually measure the coupling.
And you see whether or
not this is in agreement
with the standard model, which
is this blue dotted line here.
And you see it is.
And that plot here tells
me that the Higgs mechanism
is responsible for the mass
generation of this particle.
So it might be that there
is a mechanism which
is very similar to the Higgs
boson which results in the very
same observations
in nature, but it's
not quite what we have
in the standard model.
In order to make
those statements,
one has to improve the size
of the error bars here,
or the statistical significance
or the significance
of the measurements.
That is part of our program.
That's what we're trying to do.
All right.
In summary-- again, this is
a very high-level summary--
we measured the mass, we
measured the spin and CP
of Higgs boson, we
measured the coupling
to the Z, the W, the top, the
bottom, the tau, and the muon.
We have not been able to measure
the coupling to lighter quark
masses--
strange, charm, up, and down.
We have not been able to measure
the coupling to the electron.
That would be spectacular.
And we have not measured
the coupling to itself.
So in the standard
model, the Higgs boson
can couple to itself.
So we have diagrams which look
like this, Higgs, Higgs Higgs.
And we have not been
able to measure this.
This is not free in
the standard model,
and this would be closing
the argument that the Higgs
boson requires mass--
or the Higgs boson
is the particle
predicted in the standard
model giving mass
to the W and Z boson.
If you want, you can take
the strength of the coupling
here as this lambda.
This is the lambda
term in our potential.
So that's what we are trying
to measure in the future.
But there's more open questions.
Maybe there's more
than one Higgs boson.
The Higgs-- adding one
duplet to the standard model
with this potential is
one possible solution
to the problem of
generating mass.
But you could have very well
added two, or m, or triplets,
or more complicated things.
And so the question is, are
those maybe realized in nature
or not?
Will more precision
tell us something
about the Higgs boson?
Are there decays of the Higgs
bosons of nonstandard model
particles, for example the Higgs
boson decaying into those guys
here, which could be
evidence for that matter?
We have looked.
We have not seen this.
But more precision might
give us a different answer.
That's basically the status
of the summary of where
we are with the Higgs boson.
Again, much more can
be said about that.
And you will see this
every now and then
in seminars at MIT
or other places.